it's a beautiful day to be alive
[ __ ] Monday August 8th you're
alive and kickin Oh better than you you
know say just remember Isis got cable TV
so you don't want to get caught on that
camera till they [ __ ] around texting
his [ __ ] did you don't like a shot head
it's a beautiful day the birds ain't
singing the sun's not shining you know
what I don't give a Frenchman's [ __ ]
we're still on a mission from [ __ ]
debt you understand me
we footballs and nothing but [ __ ]
hard on a Monday morning the [ __ ] you
gonna do sit down worry about the Zika
virus I got bit by a mosquito who gives
a [ __ ] you rub some fucking's chocha
juice on and you backed up there
swinging dick and giving out all the
grass understanding
we smoked them some tremendous wouldn't
leave the Tulane I thought it was
gorillas it's really Godzilla you follow
me some Japanese people I don't [ __ ]
know maybe Japanese people growing wheat
today and I got this [ __ ] in the last of
the perennial G I got some [ __ ] white
inside that's mixed with toenails and
[ __ ] listen we got the weed that the
[ __ ] Frankenstein this week done
suckers so strap on a pet
we got a podcast tonight at sticks we
got a podcast Wednesday we got done the
Thursday Friday Saturday to show is
Friday to shows [ __ ] Saturday what
what Joey what's with the [ __ ]
advertising smoke that manga let's do
this [ __ ]
Oh
nothing like a Monday [ __ ] morning
wake up blasting I'm Sam with your uncle
Joey
let's finish this perennial [ __ ] this up
already
we got a big day planned a lot of [ __ ] I
don't know if I put a digit trip today I
got on board so [ __ ] bad on Friday my
four muscles are [ __ ] up run some
errands I had to meet some people from
other jujitsu on Tuesday and Wednesday
and continue my [ __ ] quest to lose
this fat round my [ __ ] ass ball
SACNAS stomach in the stem you'll be
some honest with myself coming in
we didn't think of that that's a [ __ ]
cloud enjoy understand me that's a
cumulus cloud right there if you have a
salt [ __ ] it's still burning in my
soul but anyway who loves you more than
me
nobody who's out here banging out with
you [ __ ] at 10 to 8:00 in the
morning slope with some real
[ __ ] weed huh who's out here
weather Esther he's [ __ ] pothead I
love pineapple is at the [ __ ] daddy
uncle joey's he on a Monday
[ __ ] grab your balls get out
there and tell the world while you're
taken from me understand me you ain't
even ask him no more [ __ ] once
you start asking you slipped
you want something you [ __ ] taking
[ __ ]
I love the smell of marijuana in the
morning I think these [ __ ]
don't let me do anything with stand up
if I let me don't let me go I'm in the
movies I'm like a problems but you know
what I didn't give a [ __ ] I think it was
[ __ ] I took it that's it [ __ ] get up on
that stage and you've taken from these
[ __ ]
whatever your [ __ ] stage may be
whether you're a painter a [ __ ]
artist a drum who gives a [ __ ] jack
you want some you [ __ ] take the [ __ ]
asking permission permission is for
[ __ ] [ __ ] you follow me the [ __ ]
you think I'm over here plant I asked
him you did think I'm here in the
mornings plotting my [ __ ] mission
that has permission to steal [ __ ] you
when they steal it's fine we steal we
get in trouble - [ __ ] you I take it now
I wanted to be a [ __ ] stand up it
took it I'm gonna have a [ __ ] podcast
and I'm a [ __ ] you we took it
we don't give a [ __ ]
I think spigot is really same you see
what happens you get me all excited your
[ __ ] it's gonna kill uncle Joey
on your own you gonna give me a heart
attack one day a lien well I'm doing
this [ __ ] thing with you guys that's
it that's that you get stopped you plan
your mission and you go implement it
that's it that's the best you could
[ __ ] do if you fail you do it again
till this day you do it again Wednesday
and eventually the mission [ __ ] hit
you're there hanging out with Tom Cruise
with a bunch of black people and that's
it was better than [ __ ] you huh
I'm ready on a Monday morning expect you
[ __ ] to be ready today's the
day today is that they're come out like
a bat out of [ __ ] hell you understand
me
tremendous I smoked one what bulk of the
[ __ ] Godzilla on the fall of the day
where you think look at this day [ __ ] it
started right got time to be [ __ ]
around today these [ __ ] are talking
about that [ __ ] vacation the wedding
they went to gives a [ __ ]
I'm talking about Congress [ __ ]
with your soul do you understand me I
went to this party I got to wear my ad
oh I did get the [ __ ] out of my face I'm
talking about conquering your [ __ ]
demons and getting out there putting
your dick in people's [ __ ] mouth
I can't wait the preseason football
together [ __ ]
how much more time think how much B this
you're gonna make their own preseason
football huh
[ __ ] it get out there snap a
[ __ ] like I said it's Monday
dawg you can't go out there have week
know each year live
who doesn't like that mmm who hangs out
we got a [ __ ] Monday morning and get
your fired up ready to stab a
[ __ ] that's the state of mind on
a Monday morning
that's not your state of mind go back to
bed I wake up Tuesday and try to get my
focus but you can't [ __ ] make it into
a society half a [ __ ] does
and that's it and that's that
I had my smooth at the when I ship I
wash my [ __ ] now I'm saying the devil I
did my [ __ ] little poll with you guys
that's it I'm off to start the day
I'll see you [ __ ] tonight six
o'clock storm to the [ __ ] gills ready
to drop some profit knowledge you
understand when that time the [ __ ]
around
I love you guys have a great day get
your tickets addenda don't come crying
to me they don't go Julie
I don't know what he did take I told you
[ __ ] Monday comes up I love you guys
stay black it's over